[Inaudible].
So I think I'll tell you what I've
learned over the last year.
Um, I've traveled to
about 160 cities since last January with
my wife damning and, and, uh,
spoken to about 300,000 people of live events.
And so the first thing I learned was that for some reason,
I can travel to 160 cities and speak to 300,000 people.
And that was a shock in itself that it's a continual
shock that everywhere we go,
there's a massive hunger for
whatever it is that I happen to be talking about. And,
you know,
I think about that constantly when I'm discussing what I'm discussing with
my audiences, trying to understand what it is that's
driving this. Um,
I do that a variety of ways. You know,
one of the things I do is listen for silence.
If you have 3,500 people in the auditorium
and they all fall dead silent,
what that means is that you've touched on something of,
that's a universal importance in that moment, anyways,
because if it's supersedes the topic supersedes,
anything else that's being considered, right?
It's supersedes the desire to shift your position in your chair,
supersedes the desire to whisper to your neighbor. It,
it grips your attention completely and, and forces the silence.
And it's a very interesting thing to, to,
to listen for that because you see that people are in the grip of something
and then you have to puzzle out what it is that they're in the
grip of.
I can tell you some of some about that. Um,
you know, there's this idea that became very popular in the 1960s.
I just talked to Bishop, uh, Bishop,
Bishop Barron about a week and a half ago for my YouTube
video channel and for my podcast. And
I told him that I was a strange psychologist because I never told my audiences
that now I speak to individuals in the audience.
I never tell someone that they're okay, the way they are, you know,
there's this idea that came up in the sixties, that you're okay.
The way you are. Yeah. And well,
I like that idea very much. And I think it's a very bad idea,
especially,
especially when you're talking to young people who are lost and nihilistic and
depressed and suffering and aimless and ideologically
possessed and prematurely cynical,
because they're not okay the way they are. And if you tell them that they are,
then they think, well, this is it, that's it that's life. It's like,
I've hit the pinnacle at 18. I don't know anything about the world.
I haven't contributed anything to it, but there's no op because I'm okay.
The way they are, the way I am. It's like, you know,
okay, the way you are, especially if you're 18,
you've got 60 years to put yourself together and you better,
you better be better at the end of that than you were at the beginning or
something has gone seriously wrong.
And so it's not an optimistic thing to tell people that they're okay,
the way they are. It's a pessimistic thing,
because what you do is denigrate what they could be for what ER,
and I know that is a terrible idea.
Technically speaking from a psychological perspective,
because it's who you could be that imbues your life
with meaning it's not the only thing. I mean,
you have your friends and your family, but they expect something from you too.
You know, they expect the best from you.
They expect a certain amount of improvement, especially if you have children,
but even if you're are a child,
you might expect some improvement from your parents as well. Um,
but that's what you hope for is you hope that the person can manifest what's
best in them. And if they don't do that,
then you're disappointed in them just like you would be
inexorably or are inexorably disappointed in yourself.
If you don't manifest what's best in you.
And I think that that's very moral law. No.
Um,
I talk a lot to my audiences about what I believe to
be in controvertible facts.
And I think that the fundamental in country,
or in controvertible fact is that life is suffering.
And I think that that's why that's a primarily primary
Axiom of religious belief in some sense,
almost regardless of the faith and the life is suffering.
And everyone knows that,
although they don't necessarily like to admit it or to talk about it. I mean,
you don't have to scrape beneath the surface very far in someone's life to find
a tragedy.
If the person that you're with doesn't have something pretty
awful happening to them, right at the moment,
economically or socially or within their family or physically or mentally,
the probability that someone they love has a problem of that sort is
extraordinarily high.
And if you happen to be among the fortunate minority for whom that isn't true,
well, all you have to do is wait and it will be true
soon enough and sooner than you think and worse than you imagine.
And so, and everyone knows that.
And so it's easy to understand
why people become cynical and bitter and hurt and
nihilistic. I think there's a progression in life.
You know, if you're naive, you think that
life will be easy and that people are basically good.
And then you have some experiences if you're not sheltered too much,
and that gets taken away from you because you betray yourself or
other people betray or,
or you encounter a tragedy and then your negativity is shattered.
And the most likely place that you'll go from there is into something
approximating cynicism,
because you don't know the alternative and your initial faith,
which was not faith, but naive.
It is shattered by the terrible reality of what you encounter.
And then you, as a cynical person,
you're more wise than you are as a naive person.
And then that's a strange thing because you're worse in some sense than you
were, you know,
you're not as optimistic and you're not as filled with hope and your life is
more difficult.
And you're probably harder on other people and with more of a tendency towards
cruelty. And none of that seems positive,
but there's a wisdom in cynicism that the naive lack,
but the problem is there that cynicism is not a
useful antidote to let's say,
tragedy and malevolence,
because there are places that you go past cynicism as you approach
wisdom and it's wisdom that you need
in order to fabricate yourself,
this sort of vessel that will keep you afloat during
stormy times.
And so I talked to my
audiences about wisdom
and I think I tell them other things that I believe to be true.
It's like, well, life is difficult,
mean it's tainted by malevolence and it's cast and
tragedy,
and you need something to offset that because otherwise they'd embitters you.
And if you're embittered,
then you become vengeful and cruel inevitably,
and then you make everything that's made you worse, worse in turn.
And there's no bottom to that. You know, as, as anyone who's Steven him,
moderate student of history soon comes to understand,
well, there's an idea that hell is a bottomless pit.
And the reason for that is that there's no situation.
That's so terrible that there isn't some fool thing that some idiot can do that
will make it far worse. And it's reasonably probable.
That you're that.
And so the question is what might constitute an alternative to that?
And if there is an alternative and you know,
I learned a while back a long while back reading religious mythology,
mostly that there's a difference between thinking
and paying attention and of the two paying attention is much more important.
It's not the same thing as thinking like when you pay attention,
you're looking for what you don't know. Like you,
you kind of detach yourself and you watch and you listen and you see if things
are the way you think they are and you,
you hope they are because life is easier. If,
if things are the way you think they are, but if you find out that they're not,
and you're paying attention, then you can,
you can weave and you can Bob and you can adapt and you can learn.
And so you have to learn to pay attention. And
I just ask people when I'm speaking to pay attention to what they
already know,
here's something that everybody knows, No,
in a world that's consists of suffering and malevolence,
who is it that you admire, or who is it that you don't admire?
Those are the same question. If you know who you don't admire, well,
then you have a negative model and you can go for the opposite.
And if you know who you admire, well, then you can copy that.
And the instinct for admiration is an instinct for imitation.
And we're very imitative creatures. And
our,
our instinct for admiration is the instinct for imitation.
And what would you call it deeply? Biologically admitted,
physically rooted guideline to the proper path of life. The question is,
is there a proper path of life? Well,
there are certainly pathways that make things worse.
That's something to know you could avoid those.
And if there's something that if there are pathways that make things worse than
there, there, there are the opposite pathways,
even though those might not be so clear, I think that's why we're often.
So enamored of, of evil characters in,
in fictional representations is because it's clearer.
It's easier in some sense to make what constitutes the dark path clearer.
It's easier for people to understand,
whereas the path that's positive is murkier and more difficult to
ascertain, but at the very least, you know,
it's the opposite of that say, well, who do you admire?
Or we could start by who don't you admire? Well,
you don't admire an adult who won't take responsibility for himself
or herself. And could, you know,
I understand there are people that are so broken and hurt that they need
help constantly because they can't take responsibility for themselves,
or they can in small ways, but not, not completely,
but you don't admire someone who won't take responsibility for themselves.
In fact, you have a sense of contempt for that.
And if you happen to be that person,
then you'll wake up in the middle of the night and berate yourself with what's
left of your conscience for failing to undertake your moral duty,
intrinsic moral duty. And you can't escape that.
And that's so interesting. No,
that you can't escape that if you were the creature who could invent your own
values, as Nisha suggested as an antidote to the death of God,
then you just forgive your transgressions and you wouldn't suffer the bitter
pangs of conscience, but you do.
And the reason you do is because you're doing things that are wrong and you
should stop. And you know, it, maybe you can't
and then, well, let's say then the opposite, isn't it.
You admire someone who can take responsibility for himself or herself.
That's a start. And then maybe you admire someone even more.
If they've forged their character sufficiently to move past cynicism so that
not only they take responsibility for themselves,
but they can take responsibility for their family. No. And,
and they're there for the people who love them
when it's necessary. And if you do that,
then you have something I wouldn't say necessarily to be proud of,
but at least you have one less thing to upgrade yourself with
not something. And then you can move past that.
And you can say, well,
maybe if you put yourself together enough,
carefully enough spoke the truth enough. We're courageous enough. In,
in spite of the reasons you have not to be that you could also be
someone of benefit to yourself and your family and your community.
You partake in structuring things in a harmonious manner
by living in that way. It's, it's, uh,
it's not an individual focused ethos.
It's an ethos of harmony among levels. You should do.
What's good for you, but it has to be,
what's good for your family at the same time. And it has to be,
what's good for you and your family and your community at the same time.
And that works musically. You know, it makes all the levels work in harmony.
And, and you can tell when that's happening.
And this is another thing that's a great utility to note is that when you're in
that place where you're acting in the proper manner and you're facing
things courageously, and you're speaking the truth,
you're imbued with a sense of fundamental
meaning.
And that meaning is the antidote to the catastrophe of life. And it's,
it's the antidote psychologically because you have to have that meaning because
otherwise your life is too dark and too dreadful, and it will corrupt you.
So it's the end to dote psychologically,
but it's also the antidote practically because we're not nothing
us human beings. You know,
they say that we're made in the image of God.
It's hard to say what that means,
but it means at least in part to participate in the process
of bringing the good into being,
and we can all do that and the opposite.
And if we accept our responsibility to ourselves
and to other people and to our communities, and we lift that load up,
then we live lives that are meaningful.
And that stops us from being corrupt hit.
It provides us with a medication against catastrophe and it also
practically improves the world.
That's the other thing it's not just psychological it's,
you can make things worse. Everyone knows that.
And no doubt you have in many ways,
but you can make things better and they actually get better.
And there's reason for hope.
And there's something to be said to know that you're the sort of creature that
can look mortality and catastrophe and
malevolence straight in the eye,
so to speak and nonetheless stand up and do what's
right. And that all there is in that
is good. And that's what I've been telling people.
Thank you very much.
[Inaudible].